اهلا بكم مشاهدينا والان ننتقل الى ميونخ
لمتابعه كلمه امين عام حلف الناتو الذي
يتحدث لوسائل الاعلام في مؤتمر ميونخ
لديهم دوريات جويه وبحريه معا والحرب في
اوكرانيا تبين ان
الامن ليس باقليمي بل هو عالمي لانهما
يحدث في اوروبا مهم لاسيا وما يحدث في
اسيا مهم لاوروبا كلنا نعرف ان هناك
مراقبه حديثه للحرب في اوكرانيا
وهي ستؤثر على حسابات قطر وعلى القرارات
التي تتخذ في بكين
عندما تكون
[موسيقى]
القوى السلطويه
تعمل معا فكلنا نؤمن بالحريه لابد من ان
نقف معا في الناتو مع شركائنا
هذا هو سبب دعمنا لهم وقد وضحنا ذلك مرات
عديده لحلفاء الناتو اننا ندعم اوكرانيا
لضمان
اننا
انها ستبقى دوله سياده ومن ثم تنتهي
الامور الى مائده التفاوض
لكن كل ما يحدث يؤثر على المعركه وطريقه
الوحيده لضمان
سلام دائم عادل في اوكرانيا هو من خلال
معطائهم الدعم العسكري
ومن تم يقبل بوتين ان يجلس وان يقبل بشروط
ومن ثم العوده للتركي لاوكرانيا لتصبح
دوله مستقله من جديد
رسالتنا
شاب جورجيا هي ان الحرب بدات
ومن ثم الحرب الكبير الموسعه الان في
اوكرانيا
سنواصل التعاون مع شركائنا كجورجيا
وهذا جزء من الرساله التي نوجهها بعد عام
من الحرب
[موسيقى]
من خسائر كبيره على الارض
من
دبابات
وايضا اعتاد وجنود ولكن الخسارات اقل جوا
من طائرات وصواريخ
لذلك من المهم جدا
ان
نضمن ان لا تسيطر روسيا
وتسيطر على الاجواء فوق اوكرانيا ولهذا
نركز على هذا الامر
ونواصل تقديم دفاعات جويه متقدمه
لاوكرانيا هذا جزء من تقديم السلاح متقدم
لضمان ان اوكرانيا تستطيع الدفاع عن
اجوائها وحمايتها وكذلك ان كل الانظمه تصل
اوكرانيا بشكل ايضا
ناجح ويمكن تشغيله
بوجود صيانه واخيرا
ان هذا السلاح الذي يقدم سيكون
قابل لتشغيل والاستخدام وبالتالي للتاكد
انه سيكون كفاءه المساله هي مساله
ليست معركه لوجيسيات بل لابد من التزويد
والضمان ان الذخيره وكل المستلزمات متوفره
للطرف الاوكراني
[موسيقى]
تركيا يوم امس للتعبير عن تضامني وايصال
تعازيه بعد
زلزال
البشع الذي يحدث ويشكل اكبر كارثه على ارض
النيتو منذ مشاهدين اكتفي بهذا القدر كنا
معكم في متابعه لجزء من تصريحات الامين
العام لحلف
لوسائل الاعلام ضمن ميونيخ التي الذي
سيبدا بعد قليل وقال استطل قبل قليل لابد
ان نقف معا في النيتو مع شركائنا وان
الحرب في اوكرانيا تؤثر على امن العالم
للقاره فقط وقال ان روسيا تعانت من خسائر
كبيره على الارض ويجب ان نضمن عدم سيطرته
موسكو على الاجواء في هذه الحرب وسنواصل
تقديم انظمه دفاع جوي متقدمه
لاوكرانيا وسنعود مشاهدينا لمتابعه هذا
المؤتمر في سياق هذه النشره